for us in a sharper community you know
we've grown up since children with this
issue that has been at the back of our
minds you know knowing relatives that
have been going up these mountains and
knowing that they might not come back
and so when Jen peetam approached me a
few years ago to do a small interview I
said sure you know anything to help let
the world know the challenges and the
difficulties we face especially these
days with the risks and inequities that
you see bear in this film
I felt that Jen peetam did really did an
excellent job along with renown in
really conveying all of the issues that
are close to us that we haven't been
able to speak out very much about and
for me at least since the first ascent
of Everest when my father climbed with
that Hilary you know this is the most
important film Brennan would you explain
to the audience because I don't know
what does a high-altitude director do I
mean yeah I guess there's not a lot of
those titles and a lot of the films that
are out there but I guess there's a
weird cross section between athletes and
artists and this type of filmmaking in
these days and a lot of our film crew
actually got sick at altitude and
there's only a few of us that kept
working to drive the story along and I
was a big part of it just taking what we
had and modern camera technology and
making a film that documented this
really hard moment but also tried to do
it in a beautiful way what cameras did
you use yeah we we had some bigger
aerial X's and things like that but we
ended up mostly using the red camera
because all we could physically carry
I'm running across the rocks and
bringing it up to
some of the high points would the
Sherpas keeping cameras as well yeah so
a big part of the process of making this
film was also empowering some of the
younger Sherpas in the community and
teaching them how to use cameras because
they could be the only ones who could
get that intimate perspective and get
some of those shots in the Icefall so
that was really beautiful to see we
carried our own cameras but they also
carried their own and there's this
constant learning going back and forth
and we're still mentoring some of those
same budding Sherpa filmmakers as well
um Norbu since the making and the
release of the film do you think people
have changed their minds or the status
of the Sherpa has increased or people
now seeing the Sherpa for what he does I
think a film or documentary of this kind
really does tremendous justice to
explain to general public who we are you
know we are group of people who migrated
from Eastern Tibet some 500 years ago
and just happened to land on the
shoulders of Everest you know growing
potatoes and early Himalayan climbers
came in the early 1900s looking for
people to help carry their things and
that's how you know we got into this
business but this project of this nature
is very very helpful and I think in the
last two years at least I've seen
there's much more awareness of what's
going on on Everest there's much more
awareness of what the issues are faced
by our folks and so you know the work
that Renan has been doing over the past
couple of years is really valuable in
letting the world know that Sherpas are
actually people whereas the group just
happen to be great climbers and now
Hollywood has to be careful because we
have good filmmakers coming after
and I wondered what were the most
difficult shots for you and were the
most difficult shots the most
aesthetically pleasing for you yeah it's
a hard question and it was such in these
types of films yeah you just feel like
an [ __ ] sometimes when you're
pointing the camera in the face of
people who have had that kind of loss
and yeah they're your friends and they
don't want you pointing the cameras in
those moments so especially I'm going
into the homes of some of the widows was
really hard even though physically there
are much harder shot staying up all
night for time lapses at 20,000 feet
freezing your fingers that's fine but
when you have to have the cultural
awareness and respect to go into
someone's house holding a child that
doesn't have a father anymore that was
it was really hard but you know the fact
that we were there in the first place to
tell this story
you never could have expected what
happened but at the same time it it a
lot of the inequities that were there
some of the shots of Everest I haven't
seen the fictional Everest but it sure
didn't look like this this was so
overwhelmingly beautiful the shots of
the mountain and the clouds the night
etc it's incredible the incredibly
beautiful place yeah and Norbu could you
explain the religious aspects of Mount
Everest I'd never heard that before
about the goddess etc you know nature is
very spiritual for sure per Sherpas are
quite religious people we're Buddhist by
religion and high mountain passes
mountains places where we call a Oak
Hill sacred places for us and Mount
Everest real name is
Chomolungma which is mother goddess of
the world and their Darrin is the day
team you long summer resides on Everest
and for us we are like my brother said
walking into the lap of the deity and
one must be very respectful of of places
like this and they are the sacred places
like Mount Kailash in Tibet which is not
claimable just like mountains they are
rivers the valleys very sacred where our
deities gods are guests in the centuries
pass have passed and left their
footprints on and when he comes back to
his village there are these cylinders
that he runs his hands across and I
wonder do those have a religious
significance uh
called prayer wheels and prayer wheels
all over the Himalayas when you cross
the house or you know cross the pass you
see these prayer wheels and essentially
what they are is they have prayers
inside of them so when you brush them
with your hand your prayers are being
transmitted to the gods and the flags
that you saw that he was raising we call
them Lunas long-term literally
translates into long is wind and thighs
horse it's a wind horse where these
flags are raised so that the prayers go
up to the gods and and you would notice
in the film that the sharpers always
have some kind of a ceremony ahead of
time and divinations taken quite often
on what the conditions are going to be
and were quite superstitious that way
and those decisions when his times have
saved you know many of our folks